you guys have run to a third they tried
to use words that he just made up
himself
that's why she couldn't get pregnant so
she tried to get um invite row extra
contribution this will just make a board
oh what's going on YouTube now recently
I read an article about CEO of
Abercrombie stating that he doesn't like
fat people whenever his clothes
why you ask apparently we're not cool
enough to wear us on abercrombie & [ __ ]
but you don't like fat people muhfucka
button titty suffocates you there are a
million situations worries is 10 times
cool to be fat then it'd be way too
skinny to y'all right know what it is
yeah baby let's get it let's go number
one at a buffet when you're fed you
could eat anything at a buffet at least
once that's right you know what else fat
people call buffet a sampler platter
[ __ ] so that's why skinny people be in
the buffet like I wonder what I should
eat before I get fall I never had that
problem that's why I be in the buffet
life I wonder what I'm gonna eat again
let me tell you something nobody want to
be skinny and go to a buffet that's a
waste of goddamn money
get some true for you when I go to a
buffet my mission is to get the
restaurant owners to ban me for life you
know the last couple days buffet the
owner was in the corner talking [ __ ]
about me to his employees saying [ __ ]
like oh yeah Fat Boy why don't you go to
Hometown Buffet number two during winter
your clothing
red followed me clothes ah bad [ __ ] bet
you wish you had what I had
I got nature sweater Abercrombie and
blubber y'all ever notice during the
with the time all the fat kids become
the most popular didn't like this before
the one and get call this [ __ ] y'all be
huddling up to us for water every time I
deal my big ass down the hall all the
girls were looking at me like a mega is
that davis no he is so [ __ ] warm I
leave the fact when you
next us you got two chest pillows can
knock the [ __ ] out on you ever see a
terrific any man that she thank you
number four you have any idea how great
it is to be fat in the wild a hippo will
kill you a polar bear will kill you Oh
whale will kill you I'm sore Lex is
really hard to catch I've never heard
someone tell a polar bear here Cukor's
he got some blubber yeah but your
goddamn nose off let me ask you
something mother last time you saw
marine biologists looking at damn well
and be like the fat ones aren't call
number three fat people are a lot
happier this skinny people ex moaning
said you don't want to keep me people
are so mad cuz you hungry baby
whenever I'm hungry I just Nick I'll be
like
now I don't hate fitness or the gym
because keeping up with your body is a
definite must but that some of you folks
out there to take this working out [ __ ]
to an extreme
I'm gonna run 26 miles for fun Claire
that animals in the jungle they don't
got it like that even a cheater be like
you know [ __ ] it I know why you want to
wake up every day and hurt yourself on
purpose to a schedule something you do
be at the gym for four to six hours a
day you need to go home and get your
[ __ ] life together unless your job
how to do a Fitness on fella see when a
six-pack has to do with your credentials
does you [ __ ] be like so what
are your qualifications on a ThinkPad
can you read no but sick bay you would
be pretty as you want wearing your copy
on your zero dollar salary [ __ ] I
don't understand why you got such big
biceps for when you work at a Jamba
Juice do you realize you look hell out
of place looking like a convict making a
drink called a mango tango oh hold on
Mango Tango you order a rabbit ass Lucy
Babu a little idiot in all seriousness
you sir are the very [ __ ] problem my
kids nowadays grow up with self-esteem
issues because companies like yours
perpetuate such a stupid and stereotyped
look children don't need to worry about
thinking that's the way they look makes
them left of a human being it's a shitty
thing nowadays and advertisers are the
ones telling kids what makes them into a
decent human being you don't grow
another being a fat kid how to deal with
a lot of this [ __ ] too when you are
ostracized in a group of your peers
basically tell you that you aren't good
enough because of the way you look it
makes you feel like a piece of [ __ ] you
know what fat joke I hate that everybody
may in the winter well if we get snowed
in with a fat person we can eat him for
survival Oh face up if I was stranded on
an island with your skinny ass before
you even think about eating me I'm
already chewing on your leg
girl just one look
this only tough for me
slow-motion rollerblading that's why
people this is in real life time